[Musique]
même ceux qui ont signé le break ont du
mal à résister aux achats des fêtes
cette année les canadiens devraient
dépenser en moyenne 6 cents de l'heure
en cadeau de noël des achats qui ne se
feront pas tous en ligne j'ai jamais
acheté en ligne et je n'achèterai jamais
moi j'aime voir le produit
j'aimerais courage et nos artisans les
commerces éphémère comme ce marché de
noël gagne en popularité un peu partout
les clients sont à la recherche
d'authenticité et le loyer est minime
les gens peuvent déguster des produits
achetés rencontrer les artisans
c'est un petit peu plus que seulement
dire je m'en viens acheter mes cadeaux
de noël
c'est une rencontre un échange une
découverte qui une expérience des
dizaines de boutiques éphémères ouvre et
ferme les pop up comme ceux ci sur le
boulevard saint-laurent n'ouvre que
quelques jours souvent dans les locaux
vacants
on est comme vraiment 100% en ligne
alors c'est seul moment de l'année où on
peut vraiment rencontrer
notre clientèle s'inscrit vraiment dans
une tendance parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
marchés qui ont vu le jour avec tous les
créateurs qui sont présents chaque fois
puis les phénomènes de marché vraiment
très populaire ce type de boutique n'a
pas affronté tous les coups des
commerces traditionnels mais le défi
d'attirer l'attention des consommateurs
les médias sociaux de nos jours on a des
communautés dans sur instagram sur
facebook qui nous permette de divulguer
l'information assez rapidement assez
facilement
on invite les clients passaient des
précommandes donc souvent les attentes
des produits spécifiques pour noël qu'on
en quantité limitée bousculés par les
achats en ligne le commerce de détail
est appelée à se renouveler radicalement
au cours des prochaines années
mais les commerces éphémère devrait
faire partie du paysage
si michel marsolais radio canada
longueuil